Куди ховатися у разі стихійного лиха чи техногенної катастрофи?
Або - у разі військової загрози?
На тлі застережень українських та закордонних спецслужб щодо ймовірного вторгнення РФ в Україну
ЗМІ й соцмережі вкотре заговорили про цивільний захист населення.
DW вирішила без зайвої паніки перевірити, де шукати такі укриття і в якому вони стані.
Захисні споруди і сховища Києва можна знайти на спеціальній мапі.
Її КМДА оновила навесні цього року. Така карта є у кожному місті, або принаймні має бути.
Тут відмічені підвали житлових будинків, станції метро і всі споруди, де теоретично можна сховатися.
Чи відповідає ця карта дійсності?
У цьому районі позначені десятки найпростіших укриттів, тобто звичайних підвалів.
Спершу цікавимося у місцевих, чи знають вони про це.
Ну ось там на будинку було написано, далі я не знаю. Стрілочка була намальована.
Ніхто нічого не знає. Куди бігти, якщо оте - ніхто не знає.
Денис Семирог-Орлик теж житель цього спального району.
Він командир взводу 130-го батальйону територіальної оборони Києва.
Його задача у разі бойових дій захищати мирне населення міста.
Тож зізнається: раніше ніколи не цікавився, де ховатися.
Озброївшись мапою укриттів, разом вирушаємо на пошуки.
Давайте дивитися, де ми тут... Ми були отут. Ага, три панельні будинки, цікаво... Давайте підемо подивимось.
До укриттів ведуть червоні стрілки, які є майже на всіх будинках.
Он укриття. Он червона. А он друге, а он ще третє укриття. Бачите, тут все намальовано.
Попри вказівники навіть місцевим, як виявилося, зорієнтуватися непросто.
- А ви тут живете?
- Так, в першому під’їзді.
- А де укриття не знаєте?
- Ні, не знаю, ніхто не пояснював.
Укриття знаходимо в під'їзді поруч. Але всередину не потрапити - на дверях замок.
Як у першому під’їзді, так і в четвертому - такий самий вхід низенький.
Тут фундаменти бетонні, це непогане укриття від уламків, осколків.
Може в повний зріст не станеш, але краще, ніж нічого.
Стрілки на ще одному будинку вказали на підвал поруч із газовою трубою.
На безпечне укриття він точно не схожий.
Бачите оці сходи? Це ж тимчасово зроблено, разом з перилом робилося. Я не думаю, що це вхід.
Червоні стрілки на сусідніх будинках приводять нас до ще одного замкненого підвалу.
Відповідальна людина, у якої ключі, має знати, що якщо тривога, то вона має піти і відкрити двері.
За законом, укриття не повинні бути весь час відчиненими.
Але на дверях має бути табличка з ім’ям і номером телефону того, в кого ключі.
Жодної такої таблички ми не знайшли. Хто ж відповідальний і як виглядають підвали-укриття зсередини?
Це нам вдалося з'ясувати лише згодом, в іншому районі й випадково.
Лайфхак - радимо звертатися до двірників.
- Раптом що, до кого бігти до кого звертатися?
- Щас, мінутку…
Відповідальні за укриття в багатоквартирних будинках - ОСББ чи керуючі компанії, ті що раніше були "ЖЕКами".
У них, власне, й мають бути ключі до підвалів-сховищ. І ось, що всередині.
Під старими будівлями 60-70-х років збереглися такі підвали, що тягнуться від першого до останнього під'їзду.
Колись тут були передбачені резервуари для води й навіть туалети - зараз усе це, м'яко кажучи, у не дуже справному стані.
Приміщення більш менш чисте, ніякого сміття немає, але й світла теж немає.
Хоча електрика передбачена, але вимикачі не працюють.
Це далеко не найгірший варіант укриття - принаймні воно є.
Інша справа - новобудови. У цьому мікрорайоні на лівому березі Києва щільність населення дуже висока.
На карті ж бачимо лише… 4 укриття.
Ось одне з них. Єдине на цю величезну багатоповерхівку. У сусідів справи не кращі.
- У своєму будинку, наприклад, маєте підвал?
- Маємо, так, у нас там зараз бар. Ну, якщо приймуть, то може сховають від небезпеки.
Далі - кілька висоток в ряд. У кожній по 900 квартир.
- Ми шукаєм укриття. Є у цьому будинку укриття?
- Нє, немає.
Підвали є.. Хоча… Напевно ні, підвалів тут особливо немає.
Офіційно в нас немає укриття, це офіційно. Поки грім не гримне, ви ж знаєте, мужик не перехреститься.
Треба, мабуть, за місто їхати ховатися, в місті важко буде сховатися.
Невтішну ситуацію з укриттями в столиці визнають у відповідному департаменті КМДА.
За нормами, на кожні 400 квадратних метрів площі має бути одна захисна споруда.
Враховуючи щільність забудови, міська влада може вимагати зміни до планів забудови.
Але такі вимоги почасти просто ігноруються.
Не всі будівельники, не всі підприємці відповідально ставляться до цього питання.
Вони можуть збудувати мікрорайон, у якому не передбачено захисних споруд.
І я як директор департаменту не маю ніякого юридичного впливу на такі забудови.
Правоохоронні органи повинні провести розслідування цього питання.
Ще одна проблема - кафе, бари, ресторани, крамниці й перукарні в підвалах.
Кожне п'яте укриття в столиці - у приватній власності.
Є навіть такі об'єкти, на які нас не допускають.
Навіть з правоохоронними органами не допускають.
Ми маємо підприємства, які повністю приватизовані, і підприємець використовує ці об'єкти за власним бажанням.
За сценарієм у випадку надзвичайної ситуації спершу лунає сирена.
Після цього треба залишити робоче місце, оселю, транспорт.
Є 20 хвилин, аби знайти укриття. Здебільшого це прості підвали. Ще є герметичні сховища.
На весь Київ їх півтисячі, розташовані під життєво важливими підприємствами, найновішому з них - 35 років.
Поняття "бомбосховища" у законодавстві вже немає.
Також укриттями можуть слугувати підземні переходи, підземні паркінги.
Або підземні станції метро - в них опускається гермозатвір.
За даними КМДА, у разі надзвичайної ситуації в Києві є близько п'яти тисяч захисних споруд.
Там зможуть сховатися два мільйони вісімсот тисяч людей.
При цьому населення столиці - близько п'яти мільйонів.
Проблема з укриттями не лише у столиці.
На всю Україну офіційно є 21 тисяча захисних споруд.
За даними ДСНС, три чверті з них придатні до використання, кожна четверта - не готова.
Тобто не має двох виходів, вентиляції, генератора.
У КМДА кажуть: з міського бюджету на це не виділяють грошей.
На думку Дениса Семирога-Орлика, який щовихідних проводить військові тренування для добровольців тероборони,
у цьому питанні слід покладатися радше на себе, аніж на державу.
Хлопці і дівчата, вас ніхто в ці укриття за руку не поведе.
Підіть, будь ласка, поки з дітьми гуляєте, подивіться, скільки треба часу, куди йти.
Домовтеся із службою спеціальною, відкрийте, може, там треба порядок навести, може прибрати, стільчики занести, воду скласти.
Можна розраховувати на дядю, а можна самим про це подбати.
У разі екстреної ситуації до укриття із собою треба взяти документи, теплі речі, ліки, воду, мінімальний набір продуктів.
Українці сподіваються, що шукати укриття їм не доведеться.
Та все ж, попереджений - значить озброєний.